hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the twenty eighth of august today you're
watching gamespot news and I've got
loads of FPS news for you today so it's
stuck into it first up titanfall seems
to have considered itself a tad title
heavy ases introducing a new pilot only
mode the mode called pilot skirmish will
be a far more traditional eight verses
eight pilot standoff with no npcs and no
titans this feature is coming in the
shooters sixth update which will also
include gameplay tweaks like options for
colorblind players and faster
matchmaking should you be considering
diving into the title it's free to play
on ears origin for 48 hours right now
some of the major changes include marked
for death as a permanent game-mode the
possibility to join late in the game
without a penalty to your team and a
whole mess of other fixes that you can
check out on site Bungie reckons those
of you who have your heart set on
finishing destiny will have your work
cut out for you bungie's community
manager David day exist said that
players will be thinking many many hours
into destiny before they finish it that
is if they ever do he explains we saw
people invest dozens of hours into the
beta alone and that was one destination
these destinations are stitched together
with our new tech so that there are so
many different locations to visit the
game offers up planetary destinations
for exploration and raiding like Mars
and Venus within Destiny's strike
missions players will get to team up
with others to complete an objective
these missions aren't essential bodegas
said players who skip them will be
seriously missing out he rounded up by
saying until you've kicked every single
loss that plays this game you haven't
finished and once you have someone else
just bought their first copy so fresh
meat Christmas noobs with Christmas
noobs now well and truly entering our
vocabularies we also got a look at the
remastered lockout map for halo 2
anniversary and it looks pretty damn
awesome the four previously announced
remastered maps include sanctuary
zanzibar coagulation and ascension max
Hoberman lead
on halo 2 and part of the team working
on the multiplayer for the master chief
collection commented on the fifth map
saying lockout was hands down the most
popular small arena-style map in Halo 2
we're thrilled to be bringing this fan
favorite back and a paying close
attention to the details and subtleties
that make this original great while also
making a couple of very careful very
calculated enhancements as for those
changes Hoberman said they've added
cover to the long walkway between the
grav lift and the smacker tower and a
dynamic inclusion to fend off a group of
enemies nonetheless should you want the
original experience you will be able to
switch that off as for your question of
the day let me know of titanfall destiny
or halo 2 anniversary is going to have
your attention in november this year
that is it for me today be sure to drop
me your thoughts and I will catch you
same time tomorrow for our top five